we are now eight days away from the NFL
Draft and ventric is in the middle
congratulations how did you do it you
throw our football better the ring on
the end since if I did and I said we're
moving to Tampa and we got in the car
and we headed south oh that's what we
did was the exact same as Chris Sims no
throw the ring on there laughing make
the flight oh yeah I didn't do that I
didn't do oh your phrase was make the
flight arrangements yes I thought it was
we're headed to Tampa now this is some
young Christian stupid meanness sorry I
was slightly more calculated than that
slightly and more gentlemanly I tried
romance was not abundant in your
engagement well no it was not okay I was
not a very good start of the marriage
husband or boyfriend er I guess I'd like
to be a romantic thing you've ever done
well every day is a romantic day in your
household well I mean except for Downton
exactly right the stereotypical right no
I think like anniversary one year in
Tennessee I took her on like a picnic
ooh I kind of like got takeout food from
a place and got it all set up right and
white checkered flag right that kind of
hole that was probably about as good as
it got for me I might steal that idea
too yeah I might do that this weekend
yeah thanks guys we have a lot to get to
we're gonna have Peter King on the phone
for a little bit wasn't really feeling
great couldn't come in but I have a lot
to talk to him about mainly how do you
navigate the rumors in the next eight
days yes my phone with the BR app every
sick blowing Patriots are looking at
Josh Rose no they're all popping up
right now we're connected to the
mothership
I mean you are Spock right now captains
Captain Spock is here you are batting a
thousand I wear the shirt Spock jokes
come out I have an awesome theory about
what the Browns should do the mothership
send me an alert alert
see on this a tree 'it's Sims has a
jam-packed
draft notebook we're gonna get into
rumors that he's hearing about the
Broncos the Browns the top five D
lineman that shouldn't be top five the
top the D lineman that should be top
five and we're gonna go and breakdown
Shakima Griffin for the first time he
just watched the film yeah so we have a
lot of draft stuff to get to and maybe
just maybe Phil Simms picks up the phone
this week I hope so if he got at least
one minute of Sun the over/under one
minute of Sun yeah and the big blowhard
I know he did yeah he seems like he had
a good time
really yeah he said he did very good I
will say it is the number for this
Wednesday is 60 to 62 we're gonna do it
like this I'm gonna say the team and you
tell me who on that team is 62 you were
very good at this from 61 yeah Buffalo
Bills guard oh I was gonna say the
center would do cam wouldn't it got that
guy Minnesota Minnesota damn it it's
Mitch burgers not 62 I knew it was one
of those for you they're all like the
same that Minnesota has these three
interior offensive linemen they
literally look like they were like white
guys cut cut out of like a cookie cutter
yeah had the same body entrance
the Patriots 62 damn I'm really crapping
the bed here hold on the center is not
62 C State
oh it's Thune Eagles Eagles is Kelsey
yep and then the Bucs
the books starting guard Evan Smith Evan
Dietrich Smith right all right so that
was not good on that one
that was rough yeah you got Kelsey
though so Hall of Fame for her Miami
center guard the 70s Jim Langer right
Atlanta offensive lineman Todd McClure
for most of the 2000s guy McIntyre
three-time Super Bowl winner for the
49ers and 80s right Marco Rivera for the
Green Bay Packers is a three-time Pro
Bowler number Adam Timmerman on the st.
Louis Rams two-time Super Bowl offensive
lineman shirt greatest show on Jeff
Jeremy Newberry Center for the 49ers ACK
in the 2000s I just remember all of
these guys from Madden not a lot of
photographers here number and then Dan
Neil the guard from the Bronco
right back in the 2000 yeah Dan Neil not
a great there's a Hall of Famer Jim
langur by than that sixty twos open
hey Kwon pick up sixty I caught Russell
Wilson show last night and I mentioned
it to Sims in the first episode I don't
know it was yes so he did I saw one with
Mason Rudolph and then one with say
qualm Barkley right and I was like Sims
you catch it last night and he was like
it was the worst thing I've ever watched
in my entire I was horrible I couldn't
give it much time I mean I watched the
preview of the night before was sake WA
I mean it's like I don't even know what
to say it's not even like real talk it
was like let's two guys and we'll we'll
just talk about how cool we are
I enjoyed it all I went into it and I
went I'm not gonna go
what would Gruden do cuz it's not that
dynamic right Gruden was must watch TV
cuz he put those rookies on like unnerve
and you didn't know what he was gonna do
yes the thing about Russell is he is
such like when I talked about people in
like philosophy he is like one of those
guys where you're like you don't really
talk like this do you and I'll sit there
and I'll go listen in life bad things
are gonna happen and it's about how you
respond like it's just constantly
reading like calendar quotes but you
hated it one I felt like that's what it
was you're right it was just like Coach
talk all the time and again I like
Russell Wilson it's not against him but
yeah just the show itself was a little
disappointing to me certainly not on the
same level as Gruden camp
no not even some of the things I thought
was interesting he during the the
regular season he swims every Monday
morning that was something I learned I
was like get the soreness out that's a
really interesting thing that I haven't
heard any other NFL player talking about
sometimes do that like you even in the
summer and and training and like this
mandatory swimming we would have a
workout it would be like a it wasn't
mandatory to be weightless exertion come
Friday and we're gonna have this
exercise set up for you and there's
gonna be coaches there we're gonna have
a little workout but it's just a good
way to get a little exercise in and not
kill yourself like I said I thought also
the Mason Rudolph one right he
interrupted Ross Wilson so man
time's yeah that I was like dude he
interrupts and it made me self-conscious
about me interrupting you yeah I was
like is that what it sounds like for me
and I was like I would never drift left
go I don't know it it I don't even
notice it anymore
I really don't it's like maybe it's
ingrained in my doctor exactly right
that's another one too I mean again I I
thought you were the first person I
thought of I went look at his body well
I mean I was like this is not like oh
like Josh Alec Mason Rudolph if I took
my shirt off a Mason Rudolph took his
shirt off it's a competition
he was never in the first round until
the Patriots had him up for a visit and
now he's in the mock trial like there's
no it makes it Rudolf goes in the first
round I will I will get on my knees and
kiss your feet when we're doing the live
show I promise yes Oh what I mean that's
gonna be yes if you draft him he yes yes
he might not even have been me in top
six he wouldn't be the next six or seven
guy from the one thing though that I
really took from the Russell Wilson show
was the sake one episode yes and just
seeing sake one next to Russell Wilson
yeah and realizing that they I don't
even think they're the same species and
Russ going I've never seen a football
player built like that before and then
Russ is throwing him Rockets and he's
one handing catches out of the backfield
Russ called him a freak he goes this
kids a freak and for me I think Russell
Wilson's a freak yeah and for a for him
to call that to say Kwan freak on freak
crime I left and was like I
oh my god sake once incredible yeah like
that's what I took from it but I agree
like I don't think I could watch five
episodes of Russell Wilson doing that
but I appreciated it for what it was but
he's definitely not a judge yeah that's
probably why I didn't like it much I was
just expecting more and I'm not gonna I
you know did that kind of talk I've been
around that kind of talk my whole life
so I understand maybe how some fans and
everything like not trying to downplay
that yeah it was a lot like when you go
through something at self it's important
that it call it a gap play and you let
it go and for someone like you it's like
I've had those conversations nine
million times I'm ready alright so I'm
gonna get my brown theory before we call
Peter I don't know I think we got to
call him let's call Peter that's a
little more of a big deal than you Spock
sorry you think so
just a hair the Spock episode of the
podcast [ __ ] numbers
they do is smock know I wore the shirt
many times I know I know I love it I'm a
firm believer that when people comment
on your clothes it means they like them
yeah okay sure
like if I didn't like his shirt I'd be
like yeah sure great long-sleeve really
fashion trends nothing what's up we're
on the podcast right now so don't say
anything you know crazy there Peter King
okay I don't have anything crazy to say
right now darn it okay fine
how you doing man sitting here I'm just
sitting here imitating Tom Brady having
some vitamin water zero I've got the A's
and the White Sox on the TV in my office
you guys are so excited about that yes
Aysen I can't even get into baseball
yeah they can't even like watch the
Yankees who are my favorite team on that
day you know why you can't get into
baseball regular dinner
no I'm just telling it because the NFL
figured out a way to ridiculously
captivate everybody on the planet for
four months by endless stupid idiotic
worthless debates about whether Josh
Allen deserves to be picked one or forty
one oh it's all this is this is really
not sort of the NFL that I signed up
cover really it's just it's insane I
just this whole thing's insane I was
gonna ask you so I I think these last
two months it's a lot of swirling rumors
I never know what to believe
these next aired twice yeah these next
eight days are those last two months on
steroids and I was gonna ask you for
advice on how to handle this but it
sounds like we both need advice I look I
wrote is my haiku the other day believe
one in every 50 things that you read you
know and and are you here because look
the bottom line is I say this to people
all the time in the in the in the
football world the way I explain to
people what has happened to the football
world is that in 2000 when I went
to cover the NFL Scouting Combine in
Indianapolis I had an hour and a half
lunch one day with Plex ago Burris who
really didn't have much to do one of the
days he was in Indianapolis and there
was 15 or 20 reporters there covering
the combine last year I don't know what
the number was this year but last year
there 1243 credentials issued for the
press at the Scouting Combine so I'm
just I mean I'm just basically saying
that that we are in an era when you know
at the end of February instead of
everybody getting lives he is listening
to absolutely worthless pablum from
coaches and players and GM's you know
just kind of promoting the NFL it's I
don't know I I I hate to be so negative
about all of it but really nothing
happens really between you know say
January 5th or whenever the last college
game is played and April 26th and yet we
make it the most exciting season in the
world if you ask the Cleveland Browns
fan yeah you know if you have a
Cleveland Browns fan he would tell you
that April 26th is more exciting to him
than October 26 and that's that's
honestly it's just a little bit sad yes
because it means that he has absolutely
no faith in his team to ever win and so
the chase has become the favorite thing
for the Cleveland Browns instead of the
actual getting somewhere it's like it's
like I've heard Browns fans say okay
let's take Berkeley at 1:00 we don't
love any quarterback so let's treat the
fourth pick again stop treating yes and
start picking yes
no enough you know I like that you just
ranted on that whole topic cuz it's
something that uh both left CO and I
here go crazy with the time just these
stories that are not really stories that
come to fruition but this is where like
I want to just hit on something you said
because all right first of all you are
Peter King you're the man you've been
king that you
been around forever your connections are
you know top of the line exactly right
around the NFL I just for you personally
how do you balance out what to believe
with some of your personal relationships
this time of the year do you know
because the coach tells him something
that he reports and there's a shockwave
right so like how do you balance you
know the coach the GM you might know the
agent you might know and how to kind of
maybe process or connect dots with all
the information they give you I think
things have changed massively in the
last say I don't know 10 or 12 years on
my on my podcast this week I've got
Ernie Accorsi and so what I did I wanted
to do something different this week and
this is a long-winded way of answering
your question but you'll get it after
you hear about this so on my podcast I
basically sat down with Ernie Accorsi
last week in his apartment building in
Manhattan and we talked for 50 minutes
right and so he for those who don't know
so of course he was a rookie general
manager with the Baltimore Colts in 1983
that was the huge quarterback draft the
Elway Marino ken O'Brien
you know Jim Kelly Todd Blackledge that
was that was the huge quarterback Draft
of 1983 and then he was also the GM of
the Giants when the Giants picked well
they ended up picking Philip Rivers and
trading him too you know for Eli Manning
to San Diego but but anyway the point I
was going to make is that so you know
this is a weird way to look at this but
but Ernie Accorsi basically explained in
both instances all the little wins and
all the little factors that buffeted him
on the way to making his pick and in
2004 I actually was part of the reason
why the Giants ended up with Manning in
a very weird way and I'll explain to you
how it happened and how it would never
happen in a million years today I don't
think right but in 2004 the Chargers had
the first pick in the draft and
everybody knew that
Eli Manning it said I'm not paying
playing for the Chargers and I kept
hearing that the Chargers were gonna
pick them anyway and I called somebody
who was close to AJ Smith the general
manager of the Chargers on Friday and I
said what's gonna happen tomorrow the
draft was on Saturday morning I said
what's gonna happen tomorrow and this
person said to me I think AJ is going to
pick Eli Manning at number one and then
when the Giants are on the clock at
number four he's going to call her any
of course he and try to make a deal I
said he interesting and I said are you
sure he goes I'm pretty sure but you
know we'll see so I made a route of
phone calls that day I didn't hear this
anywhere else and so I called every team
at the top of the draft before the draft
just to find out what was going on and I
called Ernie Accorsi and I said hey a
word to the wise I think you might be
getting a call from AJ Smith you know
during your pick and at the time Ernie
didn't think he would be getting that
call because AJ told him I'll call you
this week I'll call you on Friday right
and he never he never called him
thinking that there be a deal done
before the draft started yes yeah right
and he said and and so Ernie said he
never he never called me so I just
figured it was over mmm so and so I just
I planted that seed in his head and so I
asked him this week on the podcast did
that have anything to do with what
happened on Saturday he says yes as a
matter of fact it did because I am
always a guy who doesn't waste any time
when I'm making my pick and at the time
when they were picking four they weren't
going to take Phillip Rivers they were
going to take Ben Roethlisberger right
where they were going to take a trade
with Cleveland at number seven but he
told me I doubt I would have done that
because I feared somebody jumping up and
getting Roethlisberger turns out
Roethlisberger didn't get picked to 11
but anyway I think the Giants would have
just sat there picked Roethlisberger
right away and went on their merry way
but he said because you you had given me
that little heads-up I said well who
knows we should wait maybe eight
I'll call and he said I'll give him a
few minutes so at the seven minute mark
his secretary Janice Gavazzi yeah yes
yep Ernie AJ is on the phone and so they
made the deal in about six minutes and
the rest is history but my whole point
of telling you that story is not to say
gee what a vitally important guy I am to
the history of the NFL well you are but
go ahead keep going yeah simply to say
that times have changed and I don't
think like right now in mind this is
just my opinion yes I don't think John
Dorsey is telling a soul even people on
his own staff here's exactly what I'm
gonna do right because he doesn't want
anybody to find out so that they can you
know so that so that he can maybe get
one up or right he decides to trade I
mean he just wants to be able to use all
that power and so he doesn't want
anybody to know what he's gonna do and
so right now just my opinion I don't
think there are many people if any in
that organization who know exactly what
Dorsey is gonna do there's well I just I
just think that's a mean I was gonna say
that for later but Sims is hearing that
yeah yeah I've heard the same thing we
were gonna talk about this at some point
but to yes that I I was told that he's
not gonna he hasn't told anybody what
his plan is at number one and he wasn't
even gonna tell the owner until the
night before they get the draft so that
Betsy god forbid he talks to a homeless
person it's got yeah it's good it's good
but wait so yeah you don't think in this
day and age even with somebody you know
as big-time as you and everything it's
just the current media landscape you
don't get those private conversations
with maybe the people you used to that
you're a just don't trust trust the
media anymore no I think it's that I'll
go back to Jacksonville taking Blake
bortles mike shanahan taking jay cutler
yes they they feel like I'm not gonna
tell anybody and I'm literally not going
to tell anybody mike shanin didn't tell
a soul till an hour before the draft I'm
not sure that Dave Caldwell told anybody
until right before the pick
and and his reason is that you know
these walls have ears and he doesn't
know deep down who in his organization
or whether his owner you know has has a
buddy you know at ESPN or something like
that he doesn't know who everybody knows
and who everybody talks to so to just
ensure that nothing is going to happen
and this is Bill Belichick does this
everything is done on a need-to-know
basis remember a year where they take
Rossi dialing high in the draft is
cornerback from Virginia yes right and
and and all of his Scouts that year I
mean all of his Scouts that year wanted
either him to take jabal sheared or
Brooks read that's right okay
and so that year all of his Scouts
they're not even in the room but they're
in an ante room and they hear just at
the time that the pic is being made that
they're taking Ross idling and their
jaws hit the floor they were utterly
absolutely totally shocked and had no
idea I was in college too right Bill
Belichick tells people things only on a
need-to-know basis yes yeah I've been
there for though that that kind of draft
would New England so I've seen it happen
yes Jay you right Jamie Kyle because I
mean we're I was sitting in that obscure
room that Peter is talking about and we
got word that Jamie Collins is gonna be
picked and I'm just gonna tell you the
scouts they jaws drop they were walked
out of the room shaking their head so
you're right but bill is always right I
got one last thing for you Peter talked
about ears and and you're worried about
things getting out I started a campaign
with Joe Montana he's aboard we're doing
on the podcast the listeners are aboard
and I'm gonna enlist your help you go
again I'm a firm believer that there's a
man missing from the Hall of Fame and
his name is Phil Simms
if you don't think he's warranted based
on his playing career I think when you
add in 20 years of broadcasting I can't
believe he's not even ever mentioned and
when there's one person the media that I
think carries a big stick and people
fall in his way
it is you Peter and I'm just curious
where is it possible to start this
campaign for Phil I think it's possible
I think one of the things that happens
is that you know phil simms assertive in
the category to me of like a candy
anderson a guy who kind of has fallen
through the cracks of history right and
i mean really did so much over a you
know in my opinion he would he would he
either would have been in if he didn't
get hurt in 1990 right because you know
that obviously if he was the quarterback
Hostetler in that game you got two Super
Bowl wins you got really making the
Giants competent offensively for the
first time in more than a generation and
that and and that would have changed
everything for him right and I always
believed the injury suffered in I think
December 1990 in a Saturday game against
Buffalo your foot yes and and that
really has been a huge roadblock to him
in the Hall of Fame but I think one of
the issues now is and I think it's going
to be a big issue is that they're gonna
be so many quarterbacks yes with gaudy
incredible numbers right we're going to
be coming up in the next few years that
Phil is going to be stacked up against
these race even though his air is
slightly different than theirs right and
it's gonna be hard for him well yeah I
covered those teams for four years and I
saw how incredibly important Phil Simms
was to the greatness of those teams so I
certainly would be a backer of his in
that campaign and I wish you luck I
really do I'm dead serious
alright so this is I mean you were
supposed to come in today you're not
feeling your best so we you know we're
in your business you're in your Peter
King so but you're coming in you need
two books okay you the man that would be
awesome Peter thank you guys thanks for
coming on man we'll talk to you soon
awesome and you can of course check out
his work at mqb si.com
if you go to mmq b.com you'll see office
furniture i think you be calm that works
as well at redirects the mmq being Peter
is the Peters a point where he's so well
connected that he knows so much
information yes if I were him I would be
telling secrets by accident because I
wouldn't even remember all the things
that I found in let go the reporter
during draft season what you know Todd
Bowles Bill Belichick just told me
they're gonna they're gonna draft them
at 31 you're crazy so easy my follow-up
to that is Giants fans you pissed you
don't have Ben Roethlisberger right it
looks great Eli had to but I think Ben
could have gotten to what he didn't so
also big that's exactly but Big Ben in
New York yeah holy yeah I know this
about the big bowl that would be a that
would probably be one of the issues to
the Big Ben the one knock about him
coming out at the time was that he was
so much more immature than the other two
and Eli has been so great with the
meantime they recognized I think most
time recognized like Roethlisberger was
the most talented one
but like Phillip was like you know on
the verge of like having his fifth child
and already at that time so he was like
a grown man Eli is a Manning and he's
learned from his brother and he's stand
up and Ben was you know Ben Ben was Ben
at the time you ever said go back and
look at back old pictures of them long
White T's Gus he's and chain hanging out
I mean not your typical and he had
there's off-the-field issues which were
disgusting which were immature and a
very early point of his age their career
but that's interesting the other thing
there is here's what I understand about
the Hall of Fame yeah
all these quarterbacks are coming with
all those gaudy numbers you are in the
room because you're some of the smartest
media members that's ever covered this
game yeah and if you're incapable of
realizing that cornerback rules
defensive rules offensive rules styles
of offenses what quarterbacks are asked
to do the amount of throws during each
game if you're not able to process that
those numbers are inflated and that what
phil simms did in that era is insane
and that is yards per completion
compared to today is like double because
he was bombing it and he played with
Parcells and he played with Belichick
and he was helping with Lauren's Taylor
and he got the first Super Bowl in the
NFC East when the Washington Redskins
New York Giants Dallas Cowboys and all
those teams were at their forefront and
the Eagles have one of the best defenses
of all time right well then maybe you
shouldn't be in the room well I you know
I think that's what a little bit with
Peter saying like Peters one of those
guys that should be in the room right
but I think what he's saying is it's
hard to overcome some of the maybe
idiots that are in the room who can only
look at the bat of mine of the stats but
even even if the idiots in the room
can't look at the stats can't we look at
the 20-year broadcasting career and when
my dad retired he was in the top 20
all-time and wins as a court starting
quarterback that's a pretty big stat too
but whatever I don't really care about
all that but you did give me the jumping
off point where I don't understand why
the media necessarily gets that vote
anyways I don't understand it why as an
NFL player don't I get divided on who
gets in the writers Hall of Fame I can
read and write in fact I know more about
their job than they do about mine so why
do they get to make a lifelong statement
on some guys career to go and I've said
this before I've been in press boxes I
mean it's writing my page heard of my
article for tomorrow I'm tweeting
something out Oh loud cheer oh my
touchdown Julio Jones is good he caught
another touchdown let me go back to
writing this yes and so that's their
context of the game and he's a plus two
on that play but that's like my scouting
voice sorry it's just not it's just not
fair to me in my eyes to me that's where
a Hall of Fame has a serious flaw they
have to get the X Hall of Fame players
to vote which I think they do right I
think so and I think they got to find
some way to incorporate coaches or
player something involved in it but my
thing is this Peter is in my mind a
light a light house for this profession
yeah he shines his light on something
and then everyone reacts yeah his
article comes out on Monday the world
reacts the entire day he's more
connected in my mind and really anybody
yeah to say that we are coming up on an
issue in which in
lated stats are gonna make it hard for
people and previous generations you we
need to do something about I know but so
you can't say there's an incoming
problem and then go well everyone before
2004 screwed like that's not how it
works after the draft this summer we're
gonna kick this into high but he did say
that he would support the cause yeah so
we have Joe Montana and Peter King and
we have the hundreds of thousands of
Simza left go listeners behind us we
need to write some letters to David
Baker this summer that's what we need to
do he gave us the address I'll go back
and get it I'm gonna go bear wrestle him
to the ground like the Barry should
basically David Baker versus the grizzly
bear like he's gonna win you said you
heard that now Peters confirming it that
Dorsey is not telling anybody yes but
guess what but i'ma tell Dorsey here is
what we're doing at number one the
Cleveland Browns should select sequin
Barclays okay I said this months ago
I'm just reaffirming sure I got no
number for ya the Cleveland Browns
should select Bradley Chubb here's why
number one you're getting a generational
running back and you're getting the pass
rush duo of miles Garrett and Chuck yeah
which would be one of the best duo's in
the sport right of the sport right off
number two you're getting probably the
top two players on most teams draft
board yeah I don't think that
quarterbacks are higher than them if
you're just doing points right number
three we are coming off a final four in
the NFL where three of the quarterbacks
were Nick Foles Case Keenum
and Blake bortles for months we talked
about the quarterback position is very
important at the same time if you have a
great team you can overcome that number
four everyone's coming forward right now
in saying that none of these
quarterbacks are Carson Wentz or deshaun
Watson or Ange
none of them are guaranteed and number
five you have Tyrod Taylor you have a
top 20 quarterback in the NFL right now
I don't know why you don't lock up think
he's outside of my top 20 but good Nick
Foles was in your 30s even he was good
enough to win the super bright he was
around Case Keenum you know I'm saying
right you you have an ample enough
quarterback but you can get a
generational offensive player a lock
you have chub which I don't want to say
he's a lock like say Quan but he's a
he's Gary he's a good player no doubt
he's a lot to be a starting guy that's
gonna be at a high level and is gonna
get a handful of Pro Bowls and I'm not
saying ooh
find that next that Mason Rudolph in the
second round no maybe you don't draft a
quarterback this year I'm just saying if
you got two locks and you know that the
Giants if sake wants off the board will
probably go quarterback yeah and we know
the Jets are going quarterback yeah why
not get the locks and then visit this
next year the Browns if you don't win
the Super Bowl next year no one's gonna
freak out I just think that's the move
to go yeah I III don't know if that's
the way to go I mean obviously it's an
it's a different team I get your day
sitting there going you get the two top
guys on the board right and we'll figure
out that maybe there's a guy next year
if if you know if you're not a hundred
percent confident but you know those two
guys are gonna think that all of them
are getting back to is what their board
is right and where they have those guys
dry right all right you to pretend I
want you to think about would that be a
good move what do you not like about it
what do you like about it
um I I think that my biggest thing is
it's still the quarterback position
these guys are still first around
talents without a doubt there's still
all top 20 picks to me gotcha so the
quarterback position yes even though
none of them are on the value chart
probably as good as say Quan or chub
right I the importance of the position
is gonna knock that grade up a little
bit higher as well and to me you talk
about next year sure that sounds great
on all these rants this post I know
about quarterback just let me finish my
[ __ ] point you odd mouth interrupter
and pulled a Mason sorry this is such a
ghetto but no but
my my thing is you don't know next year
either I mean I was told all year this
is the most special quarterback class
we've ever seen and it's not as good as
last year's class right so I get that
but you don't know next year from the
standpoint of what the quarterbacks will
be okay I would just stop I'm not about
to say something and I mean it's the NFL
one year Cleveland could be in the
playoffs next year
I mean Cleveland could be in the playoff
conversation would you be shocked if
Cleveland ended up like six and ten or
seven and nine what I'm saying is if
they draft say Quan and chub with Tyrod
tannic and - that team can make the play
okay okay but I think I would also say
that I don't think tie rod is the type
of guy that's gonna bring your team too
much farther okay that's where I would
go and tie rod at the point of his
career right now okay what is tie rod in
near eight or nine roughly I think
somewhere in that category Josh a look
he's just not a franchise quarterback to
me he's always gonna be looking to
replace him and I get you could still
win the games of them right and if Tyrod
Taylor saying he's the future no I'm
just saying you're locking those two
guys into the future and we'll come back
to this little later it's a good thought
I just still still think you got to go
to the quarterback and you got to go to
the quarterback at number one really I
think because you just got to get the
guy that you know you at least have the
most confidence and out of the
quarterbacks that are in it if it's Sam
darn 'old at number one and you know
that then do you go with a story like
that but it doesn't matter what I do yes
I mean that's I've been arguing that
from the start you know sometimes I
going into his eighth year he's going
into the eighth year yeah he was hurt in
24 I mean your points are just days
really I was just I listened to you for
two months talk about how we over value
the quarterback position and the number
one argument you're giving back to me
right now is well it is the quarterback
position so I'm just seeing your
argument in going we just went through
this yeah I hear you I understand that -
I
Tyrod Jarvis Landry David and Joe ku
Duke Johnson say Quan Berkeley Carlos
Hyde and they M that offensive line and
then those pass rushers yeah like maybe
you build a team that when you draft a
quarterback next year I don't know I I
understand they betrayed your current
exist they're good yeah they are now the
thing is that this is where the
quarterback value comes in though so
we've seen this year where if you build
a good team you can make average
quarterbacks look pretty good and it
doesn't matter that were Vikings but yes
but the problem is as those teams kind
of went through the perfect year to
where none of their key players got hurt
or anything like that well I would true
the Eagles but I know what you're saying
yeah well the Eagles was the quarterback
command Peters okay but but still the
team was there regardless and I just
think we're you miss out as if you have
year where you lost a few players in
free agency or you did have a few
injuries in training camp what the
quarterback does do is he covers holes
like we see Aaron Rodgers or some of the
other good quarterbacks to where we go
man these teams aren't very good but
their quarterback can play at such a
high level he's worth almost two or
three wins for the team every year
because of what he does in the fourth
quarter so that's where do you think
sake one can have that kind of an impact
cuz I think he can say Quan could be the
best player in the NFL next year so ok
let's just let's just take that sentence
yeah if he could be the best player in
the NFL in his rookie year right then
why am I gonna draft a quarterback that
has a 50% success rate yeah
ok III totally I'm honest I get your
thoughts I know I know I I get that all
the way but say qualm Barclay could also
be open like 75 times next year and
Tyrod Taylor to decide to leave the
pocket and scramble and he never gets
the ball yeah so that's the other side I
throw to you do where I'd go damn
if Tyra would just stay in the pocket
which is my number one complaint about
him all the time right or just throw the
ball down in the middle so I you know
again I'm not trying to argue you I
don't even know what I'm saying
I'm saying your points are good but it's
still the quarterback position you don't
know when you're gonna be in this spot
and we have to take into account how
they have them drafted not how I see it
I know I just my thing is I want to know
I'm usually right I just watched the
Jacksonville Jaguars have an amazing
success with the 70th ranked quarterback
I know but you're missing the point is
that is the best team on this sport it's
not even close it's the best team in the
sport so that's where you've got to
talked about it too yeah so if Cleveland
can be the best team in the sport then
[ __ ] yeah that's right forget the
quarterback thing if you yell at me
again we're gonna fight thank God
that was a good disagreement
it wasn't even a disagreement have it
just just we're talking it out and like
I would love to fight you love it
so I want sake wanna go to Cleveland but
you know who doesn't want sake wanna go
to Cleveland his representation yeah
rock nation however does not want him to
be taking number one according to a
writer for SI been Baskin they don't
want him in Cleveland they want him to
go second to Giants and play in the
media capital the world reportedly they
approached him about pulling in Eli
which is very funny that Peter just told
that story yeah and say qualm was like
absolutely not the other reason I won't
say Kwan that I watchin that Russell
Wilson thing yeah when you talk about
the perfect human for the NFL yeah when
you talk about a guy that every time he
was around Brian Westbrook or Fred
Taylor and like all the other running
backs are like walking around he's up
there like how did you get longevity how
did you like do this and he would face
the franchise time Ronnie yes yeah he's
he's like a good guy that law handsome
as hell he's everything answer myself
and what I would tell rock nation is
you're ruining this left Co PR move
right if you go to Cleveland you link
him with LeBron yes there's already the
Instagram post where LeBron calls him
the young king yeah we can do a cross
sport passing of the torch and you can
market this kid in Cleveland as the
LeBron of football yeah why can you do
that because nobody has the title the
LeBron of football it doesn't exist
put him in the city it has low
expectations and then if you want to
move him after five six years when you
want to get that next contract somewhere
bigger and really capitalized sure but
say Quan is a kind of guy that I think
you link him with LeBron and it doesn't
matter what cities and yeah I don't I
agree it does not matter
it's a c'mon man I mean he's amazing
he's amazing amazing he is he's the
number one player in the draft there's
no doubt about that
the problem is the position to again
just like we've talked about many times
and I'm just gonna say you know okay I'm
gonna say this
Le'Veon Bell had 80 catches last year
yeah Le'Veon Bell lines up at wide
receiver
I think it's a very archaic model to
look at positions in the last few years
there's a new there's new positions
opening up all the time
now we have a position called edge when
we first started together five years ago
that was not a thing well it was
defensive ends and outside linebackers
but because they change a lot we've
called it that because the idiots of the
world even then I felt teams who didn't
even have that like distinct like they
started to realize oh the good football
teams separate these guys they don't
just call everybody or defense end but
what I'm saying is hey Kwon is as much
of a running back as Rodney McCloud is a
quarterback like these guys
he is a running back wide receiver like
you're gonna be able to move he's a
chess piece no weapon he's a weapon I
don't look at any of these guys as a
running back
this isn't Frank Gore you know I mean
he's he's not he's not running up into
that to the a gap every single time
no he's Le'Veon Bell he is Todd Gurley I
mean he's Todd Gurley except he's just
quicker that's what he is I want to give
a shout out really quick to judge
vendrick right who nailed his scouting
report last year
Malik McDowell I did because tape he's
got great wrist tape looks great with
the hands in the ground so I just you
know what do you mean Oh his wrist that
was the first thing I said about the
podcast we gave Josh one prospect last
year he scouted Malik McDowell he
crushed it didn't see the potential and
now it looks like he's gonna be out of
the league mainly because of off the
feet I gotta Scout someone for next week
my scouting I would like that let me
think about that give me someone good I
want to say is props to myself yes did
you see that the NFL has eliminated ten
helmets that you can play a next season
because they're not ruled safe and a
cool
I've been saying here yeah there are
there is one helmet the vs helmet no
Kuechly has the not a collar this is the
Alex Smith Richard Sherman helmet it is
scientifically proven to be safer and I
said why isn't this mandatory well guess
what the NFL is starting to make the
mandatory left go PR strikes again Oh
Del Posto workout video yeah today I
usually drops it around 6:30 7 o'clock
big fella call let's call that [ __ ] so
we're gonna call big Phil let me just
see what we got here on the BR app Rob
Gronkowski is going to the Kentucky
Derby after purchasing the steak and a
horse named Gronkowski man uh just
reading a Gronk story I know I heard
what about a horse bought stock and the
horse that's never buy stocks and horses
I learned that from Rick Pitino I got a
you know you know it's a good advice
never never put your money into any time
that eats while you're sleeping it's a
waste of money
hello bleacher report bleacher report up
then I thought all hope if somebody knew
and not you two jerkles today what's
that josh is here today he decided to
work today he does nothing for the
company since in a while real question
we want to know is did you even get a
shade darker since being in barbados did
you get any Sun no man you know me I I
didn't send you any pictures of me
getting into the water but I had a half
the size of an umbrella
I had my sunscreen shirts on that are
long-sleeve with the collar up and so I
look like a fool you look like powder
like the movie powder is Phil Simms his
life but I'll give you as Lawrence
Taylor stole this from once from a
comedian but he sees me he always looks
at me you know we haven't seen we see
each other once or twice a year maybe
and you know I'll make a comment about
him or something he'll look at me go man
you are so right you must eat chalk pins
because you must I'm not gonna say what
comes out it comes out chalk or
something like I don't yes right sure
curse around Christopher like in person
he tries to he does and then like three
minutes later he'll curse and my kids
are back papa
all right your son he's like a friggin
uh tape recorder he said he says my mom
and my dad said something about my my
mom's brother my Uncle Ray and they like
nothing bad but like something that
lives on their mind about him and then
he came over the house and Philip went
up to him was like you know DeeDee and
Papa said well coming up a little bit
later we're actually gonna get a little
bit of a scouting report from Philip
Sims Branson oh I'm not even kidding
Phil Philip said some comments to Chris
it's making the show today the kid is
gonna be one heck of a scout it was
actually hilarious I just loves to say
it now can he can hear it alright so a D
lineman that Chris is not that high on
his name's Harrison Phillips right you
showed it to Philip
he's Harrison Phillips okay he wears
number 66 Phillips 66 that was one of
the first things everyone might know are
you serious this guy's running 6a he's a
big white guy from Stanford I think he
had the most bench press reps in the
whole combine 42 42 reps at 225 but I
mean he's just a big old guy and he
can't really do anything and I don't
mean to sound this in a mean way but he
just there's no way you're gonna find a
place for him to play in the NFL and
some people have them as one of the top
five interior D lineman there are and
you know of course I'm watching games
and whatever else and I just don't see
it
I'm like I don't even how do you put him
on the field anywhere where does he play
I don't even understand it so then
Philip comes up you're such an who are
you watching I'm watching just this guy
Philip number 66 like I don't think he's
very good and he watches a few plays he
goes yeah I don't think he's very good
to dad I
I think he should be an offensive
lineman and I was like I wrote it down
in my notes this guy should do junior
Swezey like that and that's what he kind
of is this big you know muscle dog meat
head right that would be great as a
guard but he's just not a natural enough
good enough fleet to be a d tackle in
the NFL so you hear that fill your
grandsons gonna be a heck of a scout man
hey listen my grandson has given his
father more in from
and my son's giving me that's a great it
is one of your things yes this is why I
brought it up I don't know what a my
thing is you know college coaches of
course their job is to win football
games their school not worry about the
pros but when you look at certain
players if you know if you go ok I could
live without him not being there but I
wanted to be a pro no way he's gonna be
a be a pro as this which which I tell
high school kids all the time so big
thing is is going to high school
basketball games and he sees a 6/8
Center that's a really big strong good
athlete and one of dads pet peeves is
gone man he's wasting his time thinking
he's gonna be an NBA player if he just
goes the left tackle he'll be a
first-round pick three right you know I
there's a kid coming down the draft this
year I won't say his name he trains down
you know the training center we know
about he's a left tackle he's an
unbelievable athlete I mean he's just
got to look six seven man he's athletic
he looks the part he's gonna get drafted
and so he's they're training one day I
said hey big man Greg how you doing you
know who's this he goes oh this is my
brother yeah I said what's going on
that's you know what do you do he goes
well I'm a freshman in college I play
basketball and I said okay let me give
you some advice right now stop don't
play football for three years
you'll be drafted in the first three
rounds as a defensive end you've got
maybe one money or not right and his
brother last Eagles man I've been
telling and I said we'll keep telling
him your weight I said if you just want
to have a good little college career
playing basketball and you can talk
about it for the rest of your life oh I
was good in college and nobody's gonna
care but if you tell me play pro
football and you got drafted you made
some money and so I haven't seen them in
two weeks I'm just wondering if I hit it
cuz you know me I I kind of wore it out
pretty good just walked right away the
offensive lineman comes up to me and
says hey man that was great mr. Simms I
keep telling him you know because the
brother
to get the one I'm talking about it's
going to get drafted yeah started out as
a basketball player and said oh he
figured it out right
plus I was in college NFL teams always
seem to love when a guy played
basketball you have good feet your
athletic fill I got a question you can
play you can adapt you can you you can
you can be multiple just like a wide
receiver I wanted to be able to do
everything not just oh I'm the receiver
to the single side I'm number one
exactly you know that day is almost gone
we need players are versatile running
backs wide receivers tight ends you got
to do it all well I got an update for
you we were all rooting for Brett Favre
to get Monday Night Football but the
rumors are that he bombed the audition
he did come out today and said that's
not true
but yeah yeah I saw it I saw it well I
you know honestly good for Brett he
tried you know so yeah you can always
sit on that tractor and mow the lawn and
squat and shoot animals or whatever Phil
is from Kentucky but he's like yeah that
country bumpkin is now you're just New
Jersey doubt what I get became a Provost
so there's two things I'm not doing
anymore I'm not cutting grass and I'm
not flying coach these this is a quote
from AJ McCarron to the family that has
such strong arms I thought this would be
appropriate this is a quote me
personally I think a lot of people get
sold on big arms you look at the history
of quarterbacks in the NFL there's been
a lot of great cubies in the NFL that
haven't had crazy strong arms how many
times do you actually drop back and
throw the ball 60 yards very rarely the
game is played with timing and accuracy
and if you have those two things you can
be successful yeah I agree with that
yeah but you know the you know it's like
I wrote my notes about a quarterbacking
you know if you're looking for magic you
know he's
got it albeit I said okay go look for it
and you're going to be right about five
times out of a hundred so you're gonna
get fired all the other times because
you're looking for it so the one thing
AJ McCarron leaves out which I talked to
receivers all the time I bring this up
with Brandon Marshall when you're
running the hitch right just a little
short route yeah he goes I talked about
two guys he goes man I want that ball
coming out here so fast and hard so I
can grab it and run and you're the thing
he's it's that's wrong in this respect
strong arm guys have a confidence and
see things differently than the guys
that don't have strong arms right so
they see a wide open receiver even
though it's just a little window cuz
they're gonna throw it through there and
the guy that doesn't always call it I'm
gonna check it down cuz I'm managing the
game and I'm just playing the position
right and this'll be good at the end of
the day but when you and I watch the
film were to go man he missed about
seven out of portunities to score
touchdowns because he didn't throw it in
there you know it's like running backs
gonna knock him down twice for them to
get ten yards and and so arm strength
always plays a hand in every big game
always you need four I always say this
you need four or five power throws in a
game that can make a difference yeah you
know decision-making I mean come on
listen how smart you got to be in this
if he's covered you don't throw it to
him yeah no kidding because he takes no
chances although you know they don't
make in a big place where we know why so
AJ some good thoughts there but I want
if I might quarterback yes I could win
with Drew Brees
yeah I'm Sean Payton and then you know
some teams well not now because
everything's changed these offensive
coordinators that's another one here
guys if we could draft that offensive
coordinator or quarterback I think the
coordinators might go one through five
right you're right so if we keep talking
about all this stuff about these
quarterbacks
you give you give them a really good
offensive coordinator they're gonna make
them good players right no doubt the
head coach set the culture and then the
coordinator now can coach his guys and
they can make star look this is why we
think Aaron Rodgers is amazing because
it's not that it's the opposite we watch
it and we go oh there's nothing there to
help him he's doing a lot of it with his
god-given ability well you know there's
something always about simplicity too
because it's so simple you can go
through all your reads and all that
quick right but we as we see with him it
seems like you know I'm
over-exaggerating
but it seems like 80% of his throws it's
him moving out of the pocket just
ripping the ball sidearm or doing this
or that that's what it that's what it
seems like and as I always say go to the
Super Bowl I've said to you before and
watch Tom Brady's first 40 throws he
throws it to number the first receiver
32 times right and it's almost all of
them so you know that is deception
smartness whatever you want to say all
that stuff that's what being a
coordinator is about now and maybe we
got a lot of good ones in the NFL
we do I don't want to call you mr. Phil
Simms anymore I want to call you your
honor
Phil Simms you have been the judge for
something in this podcast that we like
to call mascot battles two weeks ago we
had lion vs. bear bear came out
victorious we pulled from the Hat on
Monday and the battle was a dolphin
versus Paul Brown your son drafted first
and he took a dolphin Simms would you
like to go first in your argument to
your pops
well dolphin with Paul Brown Paul Brown
doesn't get any weapons here okay right
so this is because he's a Cleveland
Brown dad I'm just explained that to you
but either way a dolphin verse Paul
brought that dolphin is gonna whoop the
[ __ ] out of Paul Brown on land or in
water
I'm telling you Paul Brown gets on the
ground and Brussels that dolphin that
Dolphins gonna win and just slap him on
besides the face with his dorsal his
dorsal vein
and he might take a bite out too okay
yes okay hold up Phil I have to make my
argument your honor first I'd like to
say if the court would allow this that
Paul ground was one of the greatest
coaches in the history of the NFL and I
mean no disrespect but I want to say
that because he was so great he'll beat
the dolphin Paul Brown was an innovator
he invented the modern face mess so you
know that he's going to be properly
guarded he invented the practice squad
so you know he's had ample practice
fighting against dolphins
he's the first coach to use game film to
scout an opponents he studied their
weaknesses and that blowhole it's ready
to be taken advantage Phil Phil Phil
please first if we're doing a human
versus a dolphin that alone is checkmate
all right it's a different species
number two there have been great
dolphins in our last hunt in our
lifetime Christopher flipper snowflake
but Paul Brown helped create a dolphin
that's more powerful than those two
combined Don Shula if he can create a
dolphin legend that he can end a normal
dolphin and third bringing back that
great dolphin flipper as that story was
told because I'm sure of big Phil watch
that many times flipper was harmed by a
spear attack that's how he bonded with
the young boy well Paul Broun was a
phenomenal pole vaulter in high school
he's adept at manning a long stick
perfect for puncturing a porpoise
that's not very loud Phil it is clear
that the side that you should side with
if my opponent tries to argue that Paul
Broun is currently dead well then he
would actually be arguing against
himself if Paul Brown is dead it's
impossible for a dolphin to kill him
he's already dead if the dolphin decides
to consume the legend he'll likely choke
similar to the franchise as of late I
rest my you have too much time on your
hands
okay though I'll tell you that was well
presented and everything I'm not going
to be the judge I'm sitting in the jury
box okay and Adam you came up and we're
talking to me and I was like whoo this
is really good then he kept going on and
on I said I can't pay attention my ass
is going to sleep
he's talking so much I'm the boat
against his ass yeah I did watch flipper
growing up yes and I love animals and I
love dolphins and flipper is one bad
dude I know he could get humans on
laying down a trouble so right and he
could talk I mean what else could yeah
I'm going with flipper yeah flipper on
land I mean of water we know it's over I
mean compulsively nobody was even great
he can handle problems in this town of
water I will bet you a dinner
flipper win okay I guess we'll have to
prove it let's dig up all let's get him
against way talking about the debate as
far as from the people in the podcast
when they vote he's saying he's in he's
saying flippers gonna win oh the Paul
Broun wins he'll take us to dinner all
right Phil thanks for nothing well you
know me I saw Adam without a shirt once
I could cost me a lot of money exactly
right we got any football here today or
we just you know I don't know I think
the draft is coming about all right
we're gonna give you left go can't take
it because he's got to open his big
mouth for the whole show so you're
talking into his time here 10-minute
filibuster about the Dolphins I know
okay all right just give us anything
from the draft I know you've been
watching more and more players here what
anything they're yelling out to you you
can just go off on whatever you want
oh no no it's abroad I'm organizing my
thoughts today and I am sitting here and
our well I didn't do it Nicole types
amount is not write them down and you
should see some of mine because she
can't read my writing so okay I got it
don't worry but I I'm like sitting here
now and after a couple hours I'm like
damn I'm confused I can't remember why
what's going on so you know I don't know
I'm just watching everything I'll just
say this I can't wait for the draft whoo
you know I really can't just because of
all the stuff and everything now it's
amazing now on TV it's turning to Josh
Allen Oh No
oh and you know what makes me starting
to believe it that he will be taken by
the Browns just this these staunch
unbelievable Sam Donald once in a
lifetime and all of us the other word I
heard Oh Oh Trent Dilfer said it today
which I know he watches a lot these some
really word I would never use that he's
going to be basically once in a lifetime
kind of player transcendence but what
that transcendent transcendent you know
first thing I wrote down
what's a franchise quarterback and
because we're gonna talk about it I said
well first off dole Dean start out with
telling me he's a winner or he has it
cuz I don't care so I did the yet he's a
winner
now how many college quarterbacks have
we've seen when national championships
go thirty four to in their career and
not even make an NFL team right or John
Elway who went three and seven in his
senior year and retired as the most
winning quarterback in the history of
the NFL I love all that and of course
the arm straight thing with AJ McCarron
so we kind of splice that around alright
I'll be Sam darn 'old just and I like
him too yes he's a first round
quarterback he could be a really but how
they're now going well you know it's the
Southern California mafia that's what it
is right can't believe it alright so
wait this is last thing and then
seriously answer this quick and we're
hanging up quick okay I want you the GM
this is not anybody else the GM this is
you Phil Simms you're running the New
York Giants oh yeah oh boy I'm just
saying who would you pick if you were
the New York Giants if you had the first
path you know if you had the second pick
like they do and you're there okay
whose would you change your big board
if I was if Josh Allen is there I'm
taking Josh Allen okay now if Josh
Allen's not there are you gonna go say
Quan or chub or you gonna cuss or is
another quarterback that is a great
question no I don't I don't think I
would take a quarterback I would
probably go say Quan Barclay yeah that's
the way I feel too yessum says the
Giants you take Josh Allen or say Kwan
Berkeley where it's going national right
now you know you talk over each other I
can't hear you I mean it's like talking
it man it's like talking to to your go
inside and talk to my two-year-old
grandson and I understand him better I
do you - all right well we're hanging up
on you love you maybe just come here why
do you come here next week and we'll do
it in person no we can't do next week
the week after you're doing it we're
gonna do Tuesday you don't owe you what
are you doing next week we're doing
every day we'll call yeah well you know
I'm coming to New York next Wednesday I
got to do something I just don't know
exactly what we'll talk about I like to
do it in person
we'll see ya see ya cfl he's gone off
the rails - that's great I can't believe
I wasn't sure if he would he gets very
careful about tonight answering anything
Giants going to get sprayed he doesn't
want to be disrespectful to the Giants I
mean but I know think I know clip out
that well I know pissed when that
becomes news so no he knew he knows
we're gonna make it knows he knows I
just I know he's watched chub and and
Barkley and he's watched he's getting
there where he's watched all like the
top three four or five guys at every
position here right so I know he has a
little context that's why I wanted to
hear him say it
let's dive into Sims as draft notebook
you already mentioned the defensive
lineman that doesn't make sense in the
top five in Harrison Phillips top five
of the d-line top five of the position
yes of the deal I don't even understand
that one but there is ad lineman because
I would ask you well then who takes a
spot right and you have a guy that's not
being mentioned in the top five that you
think should be
kid from Florida State oh I mean okay so
the kid Josh sweat right all right I'm
gonna just pull up his measurables here
so but Josh sweat okay here's a guy now
there's some medical questions right but
he's one of the I'm getting to the point
here where you know of course I'm still
watching and yeah I'm almost done with
everybody I gotta watch some offensive
linemen left and some tightest yes so
I'm almost there but I've gone back to
you know whatever people have said our
top five top six in their position right
and now I'm getting the point where I'm
getting deeper down the list and I'm
starting to just go with guys that I see
numbers that are pretty amazing and Josh
sweat of course is one of those guys at
6:42 51 and he ran a 4-5 340 and has a
thirty nine and a half inch vertical and
124 inch broad jump that's pretty
phenomenal and you're like okay so these
are all top of the charts so let me go
see what this guy's about because his
sack
aren't that great and all this so and I
knew I remember as in fact I'm gonna I'm
literally gonna die I want to write what
I saw I want to say this too this is
gonna be our fifth draft together right
this is something that Sims doesn't miss
on when it gets to the guys that no
one's talking about that are athletes
that for some reason don't get mentioned
Sims is usually very good at identifying
yes so III thank you thank you for that
this is the first thing I wrote I wrote
damn I know this guy
I always thought number nine on Florida
State looked freaky okay cuz I don't
know who the hell these guys I'm
watching everybody I always looked at
that was like damn I don't know who that
number nine is good New Jersey damn he
looks like he's an NFL player so I
turned it on and I go damn wait this is
the edge pass rusher wait okay it's play
five it's play ten it's like he's
playing head up a five technique like a
defensive big Richard Seymour okay like
just setting the edge he's not even
studying the edge he's literally head up
on offensive tackles in the ACC or
Florida and the SEC and just go and his
place strength is off the charts first
of all I mean it's off the charts it's
Jadeveon Clowney ish I would argue that
he pushes tackles back and as
consistently as some of the good
defensive tackle
the draft like the top-tier ttohi which
is probably why they're playing in there
right so and you made the point to like
oh well so far to state was just trying
to get their best eleven on the field
and I was you're exactly right Adam
that's what it's happened he is a guy
that has in the NFL he is going to be an
outside linebacker or but we would say
maybe a four three Russian he's so
strong at the point of attack he could
be a crashing which would be the strong
side for three defense end right with
the tight end what range you looking for
this guy well it's gonna be about the
medicals that I've checked out because
of course when I watch them too and then
I call a few people and I'm like why is
nobody talking about the one of the
freakiest people I've seen on film to
this point and there was some few
medical issues he dislocated his knee in
high school tore his ACL almost had his
leg
okay and you could see a little of that
like Alabama game and I watched that
full game back there were some moments
where I was like him there's something
his knee is a little run weird he ran
weird then but as the season goes along
it looks better looks better right
interest cuz you notice stuff like that
I do I do something off with the body
definitely definitely do I mean I'm a
self-proclaimed master of naked men yeah
but first of all the body the numbers
that we just explained at the combine
though they're very close to Jadeveon
Clowney except Jadeveon Clowney was 267
i think so he's 16 pounds heavier but
the kid doesn't really get to play the
position he'll play in the NFL which is
coming off the edge as a freak top two
your pass rusher Belichick said that in
this press conference that I watched on
Friday what do you say he was just like
listing the amount of things that he
looks at people and it's like were they
asking him to do right he should be
right exactly capable of doing what we
would need him to do exactly it takes a
little bit of projection he was 266 when
he came out so he's he's 15 pounds
heavier and they ran the same 40 time
and guesses this kid has a better
vertical than Jadeveon Clowney correct
so that's I mean that that in itself
okay this is where same broad jump to
all the scouting experts and everything
like you just got a look at that right
there ago the NFL first two rounds are
about a leanness and you're crazy as
long as his medicals check out he is
going in the top 40 of the draft I can
guarantee that unless people just go his
knee is really messed concerned right so
that's the big thing but he's a guy that
certainly don't be shocked to be here
about this guy's a superstar in the next
few years
but I was really intrigued with him and
he was a phenomenal all-around football
player awesome so that stuff you're all
gonna get here Josh sweat Florida State
I say that Sims nails in a lot and last
year was a great example through the
entire process you were going why is
nobody talking about Carl Lawson out of
Auburn right he goes to the Bengals in
what round fourth I believe a fourth or
fifth right federic looked that up and
then he ends the year with a ton of
sacks and people are eating a half that
meanness on this guy who's all over
Aaron Rodgers in that Green Bay game
right number right so we are creating
the Carl Lawson Memorial Award for what
are people watching right and you have a
guy give it to me Rutgers give it to me
Rocco are you are you are you you went
back and you watched kamoko true kamoko
Terry you left and went left go I found
a first-round pick hands again ever
heard of them again right no again he's
a guy that I've had him on my list cuz
I've kept going I'm you know when he
combine happened I went damn he's 65 to
52 and he ran for six five and he's you
know again length of arms things like
that that's the other thing that's sweat
had all right just to going back to 14
he had 34 and 5/8 inch arms that's a
normal every team's gonna love that it's
a it's longer arms than Jadeveon Clowney
like a little raven Clark that's great
that's crazy long so every schemes and I
love them you got it you okay I just
wanna make sure six five two fifty six
six five 250 to Raina 465 at the combine
only two years of high school football
right he's fresh which is fresh what did
you see on the film freak I mean this to
me he is definitely one of the top 32
players in the draft and I know I
haven't seen some of the interior often
slimy but it's not gonna change it cuz
this is a pass rusher it's not gonna
matter right he is definitely one of the
most natural pass rushers in the draft
as far as body movements go like I've
told you Chubb is a better player than
Harold Landry right Harold Landry has
some very special elite pass rushing
skillset that you see at an other elite
pass rushers right you try to follow
formulas from your past that make people
successful like Von Miller that's why he
was the number two pick in the draft be
said about he's 40
his his 10-yard splits amazing yeah and
he can put
his right shoulder down to the ground to
where he can turn the corner and it's
like an inch above his foot but he's
still running four or five of his
running around the corner and that's the
thing this kid can do really this kid
like that he has got tremendous been and
of course he can set the edge he's not
as strong as a Josh sweat at the edge
but again it's another guy and I didn't
even talk about this with Josh sweat
either but like Josh sweat Harold Landry
this guy come on code Turei am i sitting
right Turay there this is the other
thing like so the numbers and then I
want to talk about the 10-yard split
because with this position the 10-yard
split is gonna beats everything
everything I mean nobody nobody honey
you Harris what a run how do they run to
the 8 yard point to get to the
quarterback right and these guys have
numbers that are like elite NFL
receivers in the in the town but this
guy I don't know why nobody's talked
about him I'm going to give me it's
because they don't want anyone no I'm
sure that's the NFL for sure but I just
don't even understand how Scouts just
Scouts the media people like public is
he played for Rutgers I mean maybe but
again the numbers of the combine should
lead you at some point to go I got a
watch just because the numbers are so
good that's what I'm of Carl Lawson
exactly right so I just the end I'm
getting to that point where I looked at
him and I just said wow I mean you know
is he as good as Landry or Davenport or
Chubb no but he is a first-round pass
rusher for sure and I even wrote at the
end I mean he he could be Yannick and
Gok way he's certainly a better prospect
than in Gok way was coming out and he's
a better prospect that DeMarcus Lawrence
was as well
Wow who was DeMarcus end of the first or
early second I think he was five right
or something in there so to me yes he
screams it he could play for three rush
end which is yannick and gaku a weak
side lemon and a 4-3 line or he could
play a three-four outside linebackers in
gaku a your PPC - yeah I mean he reminds
me yes and gawk way now a back way on
coming out in the draft I saw things
that I like he's got a pretty good first
step but he ran a four seven at the
combine and I was like man maybe he's
not quite as fat yeah this guy I really
don't have those questions with so there
again I mean he is
only a top 40 pick for me I would look
at it and I'm gonna do my mock draft at
some point this weekend cuz I have to do
it I mean he's going to somebody for me
in the top I'm gonna mean it's just when
I get down to it he's gonna be somewhere
25 to 32 other one the Jaguars all right
so that means appreciate I mean what are
the Patriots got what 21 and 32 30s it's
another guy I was just like damn I mean
Bill's gonna watch this guy and go okay
yeah three four we know that bill loves
Rutgers yes so one guy that we think
that you believe as a tad overrated is
Harrison Phillips yeah one guy that you
believe is underrated is Josh sweat and
the guy that no one's talking about that
Sims is trying to put you on to is
kamoko Trey out of Rutgers might not be
surprised if he goes early yeah I want
to get to some rumors that you're
hearing yeah we've already talked about
the John Dorsey rumor right you're
hearing a little love affair for the
Broncos at 5:00 yeah the Broncos I have
heard that they are all over Denzel Ward
at 5:00 from Ohio State who again is a
phenomenal football player
I mean phenomenal and this would be so
that they can have the trio of Chris
Harris jr. who they're gonna give a
little bit more money to Bradley Roby
and then they would add Denzel Ward to
them yes and then you know when I first
heard it I mean of course hey that's
great certainly this gets not your
favorite he's not my favorite corner him
for I think he's four for me yes he's
really good this is a really strong
class of some high elite corners it
sounds like the quarterbacks just
because you have Sam darn old five you
still have them in the topped one
exactly right that's a no I don't want
to sound like I'm trying to be some mean
hater here it just yes it will see ranks
they go I know like him you hate exactly
right without Ward's film is so clean I
just think his game as translating to
the NFL level is not gonna be quite what
everybody thinks it was at the college
level and I think he's gonna have a I
think at the end of the day he's gonna
be more of a nickel Chris Harris type of
guy which is maybe why they're doing it
man it's not bad to have to Chris
Harris's on your team but this kid is
like Ward is a really good football
player he's better than Eli Apple who
was what the number 10 pick yeah but
that was a bad pick yeah and he's not
nearly as good as Marshawn Lattimore to
me who was the 11 pick right and
again it depends but yeah as an outside
corner I like Ward but it's an outside
corner I don't like him as much as Jair
Alexander my cues from Central Florida
or my favorite long corner and Carlton
Davis yes
that that would be it but yeah I mean
again I think that's a little high for
Denzel those are gonna be so interesting
are especially because like if there's
trade opportunities do they want quit
Nelson to enter the line right do they
want a Bradley chub if he's still
available do they go with a quarterback
with all that I have no idea at the
Broncos I know the other rumor that
you're hearing is that a guy that one of
the greatest coaches in the history of
college football said it's one of the
best players he's ever coached yeah he's
won national championships he has the
ability to play multiple positions and
yet that last fact that he's played
multiple positions could have him fall
yeah and his name's Mickey Fitzpatrick
what are you hearing well yeah this is
it's not even it's not like people are
going oh Chris he's gonna fall it's more
I'm just reading between the lines of
what some of my friends are saying right
and there's two things that come up when
I hear negative talk about minkum
Fitzpatrick but what position is he what
position is he so his versatility is
actually hurting him so they're thinking
of him as a tweener not as versatile
exactly which okay okay to me he's not a
corner right that's where that first
thing I gotta wipe it out of your mind
everybody he is not a corner in the NFL
he is a he is a pro bowl all-pro free
safety that you would bring down in the
nickel situation and he could cover slot
receivers cuz he's very quick right he's
a better version of Malcolm Jenkins or a
Devin McCourty right that's basically is
you're exactly right Devin Devin I do
think he is well the second thing I hear
is you know he's from Alabama and you
know people are scared of Alabama DB's
because I know Lyndon Collins and Ray
Patrick didn't quite work out but I
understand what they're saying they're
worried about people you know people
worried about Alabama guys being maxed
out you know nick is a he's a secondary
coach so they've go well damn they're
good in college but they've been caught
taught things that NFL players know at
the college level yeah but what that
holds about minka in a way that I've
never doubted
so Minka JA I mean I was with Gabe the
cameraman here when he had the Pick six
in the state championship game right to
help Brandon Wimbush and for Shawn Geary
and Jabril peppers they were all in the
field too and he stood out like he is
and everything you hear from Gabe's
school as the kid is like in love with
football obsessed but the Bama thing is
scaring people and that you know people
all you know I mean Cyrus Jones and that
not working out and Dean Milner well I
wanted to go like damn you know first of
all you all screwed up on Cyrus Jones to
you Rawls were idiots I don't know what
you I watched the film and said there's
no way I would take him in the first
three rounds but I'll D Millner D
Miller's the guy Dean don't leave it for
a lot of these Alabama guys he did it
I'll say I'll be the first one like Dean
Milner is a guy I looked at was like
he's gonna be good I was working in New
England at the time and I saw everything
that I like to see now he did have a
foot injury and that's what people
forget to that kind of derailed things
early on in his career is everything
right and he didn't even get to he
didn't get to go to training camp and
then they threw him out in the middle of
the season and he struggled right at all
just snowballed from there
so hey again but that's what I'm hearing
and if that's so be it man somebody
outside the top ten is gonna get Minka
Fitzpatrick who for my money is one of
the most canvassed prospects in the
draft awesome all right we have one
thing left Sims Shakima Griffin oh my
just watched yeah we made a little news
here when I kind of went and defended
Shekinah around 1/4 3/8 he put up darn
near what was a 20 bench rub I got you
he was 21 I want to say but he is the
one-armed football player that was on
the UCF undefeated golden he has two
arms he has one hand correct
I apologized but a lot has it made about
what he could be he came out on Bleacher
port with an article and was like you
can keep doubting me if you want he put
up 20 reps and the bench press but Sims
I've been waiting for this yeah you
actually watched the film I did and what
did you take away well I mean he's a
he'd pops off the screen his athleticism
is I mean it's like watching Minka
Fitzpatrick I mean it's it's that
explosive just moves differently than
everybody he is straight ahead
motion and speed is every bit of 438
like Humana it wasn't just like oh he he
trained with a good trainer and or or or
you know maybe it was just his
adrenaline adrenaline but for him yeah
it just happened to be a that day his
was pumping harder so no this the speed
translate that's there it's there okay
now the he's a projection it's a little
bit like Hassan Reddick last year right
gotcha maybe I'm wrong about it you know
I love that two hundred how much does he
weigh fed room 27 he ain't playin
defensive end the NFL freak no it's
trying to watch his leg you know because
Joanna Rose on that case this is this is
the middle linebacker this is a middle
linebacker guy yes he is more he is
right all right so did he put it into
context of what you're saying he's the
same size as Landon Collins he's smaller
than kam chancellor so that does not
scream defense end to me okay and the
defensive end thing and I'm not trying
to be funny here the one hand thing is
going to be an issue at the defense
anything or even outside linebacker what
did you see on the film in which the
hand was an issue okay so rushing from
the right side of the defense the right
side the defense the left offensive
tackle drat you he which hand does he
miss missing his left hand okay so that
inside arm he can't do the inside push
push with that arm off that side and
again I'm not trying to be funny here no
you're not a true knock so the thing
that I see a lot of defensive linemen do
were they do a stiff like the crease Mac
that's he's the master of that let me
get low and I'm gonna put my inside arm
into your front shoulder my question is
is he trying to do that move he does it
on the other side with the good hand
okay but he's not going to be able to do
it which is gonna take one thing off his
resume to wear offensive tackles go I
don't have to worry about that gosh so I
don't know anything for the tricks
exactly right setting the edge from the
outside it's going to be an issue when
Rob Gronkowski gets his hands on this
guy if he's playing outside linebacker
Rob Gronkowski is going to own him if
he's still play it be so plan whatever
any big I know you're being funny and
and and you see on enough in college to
where you go oh I don't like that okay
alright so now he's all over the
and he is so explosive and he's fun to
watch but yes he's more Ryan shazier or
tell van Smith and will he will the hand
be an issue at that position there's
gonna be it's gonna be an issue this is
where I think teams will chicken out who
are gonna like him and maybe you want to
do that because they're gonna go damn am
I really gonna draft a guy with one hand
I mean I'm like that's gonna be a real
question and they're also gonna be like
damn you know gosh if he misses that big
tackle in the AFC divisional game
everyone's gonna go mean you drafted a
guy with one hand what did you expect so
it's very shallow but these are some
shallow people making these decisions -
yeah so that has to be taken to account
you're evaluating the player valuing the
player but man if you put him in the
middle of the field and let him go be
Ryan Shay I mean he is he is fearless
hitter mm-hmm he's got great instincts
and there's really nothing athletically
not to like about him it's just going to
be you have to have a plan for him
talent would almost be a Nickelback if
you wanted to go big nickel sure he's
going to be a great Blitzer like an
occasional Blitzer yeah or what I call a
green dog or right like I'm covering the
tailback man-to-man he's blocking and
now I'm gonna fly in right and I'll send
the quarterbacks like boy I didn't see
you blitzing and get hit he's gonna be
great at all that talent wise yeah what
range you put them in high Brody he's
got to go in the top 45 Wow yes that's
it stop - round pick definitely he's got
he has - how high could he go I mean I I
mean I wouldn't be mad at somebody
taking on at the end of the first
something like that I don't think it'll
happen you know this is other he's going
to the draft so I took that into account
I mean he's going in the draft
somebody's or the draft what they do is
they pull a lot of the NFL teams and
they see what range they think you're
going to go in and if a lot of NFL teams
are saying I have a first round second
round grade you might get an invitation
right and if he's getting an invitation
that means that teams have called him in
their agent basically and already said
like listen if you're there at 38 we're
taking you if you're sure though it's
not like ESPN are they enough on network
being like this kid is a talk like we're
you know we're gonna talk about exactly
what I thought I mean I thought the same
thing yeah I went into this with a
negative
mindset like I'm going to watch a
one-handed outside line it's a sideshow
right okay and but no he's he is legit I
mean he really is so I'm so happy good
you're there was a great rant he's a
really good football player you just got
to figure out what you want to do with
him maybe he's camp chancer maybe that's
you know one of the funny things I was a
damn if his brother was as fast as he
was he'd have been a first round corner
but it's true cuz I remember around the
combine he was being asked by the media
a lot about switching the safety and he
didn't want to have anything to do with
it
I think position changes around the
giraffe people get very stubborn they're
being evaluated all the time it's a lot
once you get to the team and you're out
there with the players and you see how
big defensive linemen are the NFL right
and we're all under your purse yeah
exactly and we're all under estimating
as you guys know cuz you've seen left
tackles in the NFL didn't see they are
truly walking out of a cave like their
cavemen okay and then their short area
quickness and stuff is what I don't
think everybody always realizes that
weight to be on the wings that 330 some
of these elite left tackles you know you
could take some of the best guards in
the NBA and they go damn I'm having a
hard time getting around him in
one-on-one batsmen yeah that's how
athletically gifted they are I mean yeah
so I don't think he could be that
outside linebacker pass rusher type
because against those guys went first of
all the size once they get used to his
speed and see it and of course all week
everybody's gonna go they're gonna put
their corners over there in a rush and
then they're gonna get to the game ago
okay this what kind of defensive systems
would he fit in the best yeah I mean
like team wise yeah uh you know I mean I
think of kam chancellor and that type of
thing yeah all right Jacksonville with
at Alvin Smith I mean he's he's a he's
going to fit in any system other than I
think a true three full so whatever so I
could see maybe a Rams and what they're
doing with mark bear and kind of fast
guys I mean this may be a Todd Bowles in
New York maybe in Arizona yeah
I got I got a piece together needs and
all that which I haven't quite got there
you see him as a possible end of the
first round pick yes definitely one of
the 45 best specimens in the draft all
right Shiki betcha creme Griffin we gave
you some kamoko Turei
some Josh sweat
there's been a great show the thing good
thing what I think people are missing
that I didn't tell Phil what Peter King
said but I also we'd also didn't tell
Phil about Joe Montana do we tell Phil
that we're doing this or no well yeah no
that's the hell with Phil we don't need
to tell him but this is a cool thing big
Phil's paying attention to us though
because he knew he had Joe Montana on
the pot on the pot bass again he thinks
Tomatoes I think my mom has the
Instagram okay I was a big your sister
is on it she is she yes but she wasn't
with them last week so he's obviously
doing it someone to my mom right now but
just my mom in Barbados that's the end
of the show
thank you guys for listening we will see
you for the NFL Draft anything else nope
that's it monday we are going to have
sand Arnold on set with Sam Donaldson
can't wait look I've thought about it
I'm not roasting Sam Darnell
we're I'm gonna let Simms teach Sam
Darnell that's whatever maybe we can he
can teach us how to be cool and don't
work on my chin yeah you gotta get a gym
plan no chance and then Tuesday we're
gonna have some phone calls with who we
got a lot scheduled for next week
Bradley Chubb we got Derwin James we
have Josh Rosen working on Josh Alan
that's not confirmed so these are all
cool phone conversations that will
likely come out Tuesday and then
Wednesday we're gonna be doing a
crossover pod with the guys from stick
to football I am gonna be the GM Simms
is going to be our director of pro
player personnel Matt Miller is going to
be our lead of college scouting yeah and
then we're gonna have Connor Rodgers as
our regional Scout I'm gonna be meeting
and working and we're gonna go through
the top five picks and they need to
convince me in 15 minutes who each team
should take it's gonna be fun and then
Thursday why watch the draft on ESPN and
only hear about Josh Allen for an hour
when you can join us on bleacher report
Facebook live it's me Simms and Miller
and it's on and filtered it's honest and
we're just doing every single pic for
the first round it's gonna be fun and
then why not come back and join us on
Friday for the second
you got your coffee way okay good
because you're holding it in right now I
can talk about the cough but I do want
to say one more thing about my friends
of Jacqueline charity that I'm gonna
throw it one more time for his duper I'm
trying to help people out
but again Friends of Jacqueline I'm
trying to you know host a event and it's
a great charity I'm trying to read a
script here either way but it's helping
kids overcome cancer helping their
family helping them live out their
dreams we in a kid young Charlie in here
who's the man came up had a brain tumor
and he's doing great but again if you
could donate money to it we're not gonna
be we're not gonna be mad at you I have
the website let's please give it to us
because I butchered it last time bit dot
do slash help cure bit dot do side help
care cure help cure see you re yes help
cure bit dot do slash help cure yes
friends a Jacqueline I didn't know that
Simms could be a good guy but he's being
a great one and you should support what
he supports Friends of Jacqueline Thank
You captain yes
forceps peace out homies for federic
good night everybody and for the lef koe
man I say good night good evening and
good day we will holler at you later
happy traps were a week away see you
soon